bonjour andré goretti merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl ans alors dans un
premier temps pourquoi s'opposer à la
vaccination obligatoire du personnel
soignant s'opposer au vaccin
cj simplement d'une remise en cause des
fondamentaux mais aussi des principes
démocratiques qui est arrêté depuis fort
longtemps
voilà c'est la mise en cause des
libertés individuelles
il s'agit pour nous d'exprimer tout
simplement le point de désaccord par
rapport à cette remise en cause
vous ne posez pas à la vaccination mais
à la vaccination obligatoire des
pompiers c'est bien ça la remise en
cause des libertés individuelles alors
la fédération nationale des sapeurs
pompiers a indiqué qu'elle suivrait les
règles du gouvernement
je cite sans aucun problème est-ce qu'on
va vers un conflit sur ce sujet au sein
même de la profession
je ne pourrais pas vous parler de
conflit aujourd'hui je dis simplement
que voilà quels seraient les moyens à
utiliser les moins les moyens
législatifs pour obliger les
sapeurs-pompiers être vaccinés il s'agit
toujours d'une remise en cause d'un
principe le savons bien puisque nous
représentants soient toujours hors
normes on entre dans le caractère de
résiliation de leur contrat et puis ce
qu'on leur demande de travailler en
dehors de toute problématique de santé
de sécurité sur des reniements de
carrière sur des principes de droits à
la retraite
on est toujours en sommes donc on va se
retrouver à laquelle passeport vaccinale
hors norme rapport à d'autres
professions donc il s'agit aujourd'hui
de d'exprimer la volonté de nos
adhérents ce ne sont pas des prises de
position individuelles simplement c'est
de rappeler que voilà il ya un système
qui est en place qui va obliger des
corporations être vaccinés notamment les
soignants nous sommes les les primes aux
intervenants sur tout ce qui est
intervention sur personne donc il s'agit
aujourd'hui d'exprimer à des points de
désaccord de la part qui s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui on aux adhérents il serait
justement la position de votre syndicat
et de ses adhérents si justement le
gouvernement
venait à vous demander de vous vacciner
obligatoirement le souci c'est que nous
adhérons lyon il ya des personnels
vacciner et des personnels non vaccinés
donc le choix laissé à chacun de se
faire vacciner de ne pas se faire
vacciner
donc il est difficile d'arrêter des
positions par rapport à bord je prends
l'exemple de mon département des alpes
intime
aujourd'hui près de 50% des
sapeurs-pompiers sens vacciné
donc ce sont des choix individuels qui
avait exprimé au travers une vaccination
donc les autres 50% soit ils vont ce bac
c'est sûr ils refuseront le maintien est
là il faudra que l'on que l'on exprime
voilà le la prise de position des uns et
des autres alors en cas de refus
injustement de se faire vacciner
des sanctions pourraient être prises
d'ici le 15 septembre c'est en tout cas
ce que ce qui sera à ce que ce sera le
cas pour pour les soignants le 15
septembre prochain
est-ce que vous avez l'impression le mot
est peut-être un peu fort mais d'être
pris en otage en otage non non tout
simplement parce que nous avons fait des
choix au travers l'exercice de ce métier
nous sommes des fonctionnaires avec une
obligation d'obéissance
j'ai pour souvenir moelleux 1914 où le
ministère le glânois nous avait imposé
la vaccination vers le pur nous vacciner
contre l'hépatite b
donc il fallait pouvoir et continuer à
exercer ce métier d'être vaccinée contre
l'hépatite b voit ce sont des éléments
qui aujourd'hui en tant que
fonctionnaire mais sans pause et on
l'accepté on l'accepté pas on verra
quels sont les moyens de remise en cause
de cette obligation ne sait pas
aujourd'hui il faut savoir aujourd'hui
qu'elle soit quels sont les moyens
utilisés les moyens législatifs pour
conduire cette obligation nous ne sommes
pas les seuls puisque les soignants vont
se retrouver dans cette même situation
alors il ya des choses qu'on a du mal à
comprendre d'amorcer le côté tardive de
cette prise de position mais aussi
traumatique de 2 x 2 qui va être maxime
et obligatoirement on se retrouve dans
une position aujourd'hui les
sapeurs-pompiers de vacciner les
sapeurs-pompiers sont souvent
accompagnés des forces de police de fond
de sécurité est là
andré goretti j'avais vous poser la
question les policiers et les gendarmes
ne seront pas concernés par cette
vaccination est ce que vous trouvez ça
juste on a bien du mal dans le cadre
d'une opération qui est menée
conjointement sur des secours à personne
d'autres situations où les forces de
police sont à nos côtés
s'il ya des choses qui ne s'expliquent
pas donc ces choix sont les choix du
gouvernement
voilà que j'ai du mal parfois nous avons
du mal à comprendre l'aspect tardif
l'aller les positions le caractère le
caractère obligatoire à la remise en
cause des libertés tout ça ce sont des
éléments qui qui sont difficiles à m
merci beaucoup andré goretti d'avoir été
ce matin avec nous sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole de
la fédération autonome des sapeurs
pompiers professionnels merci beaucoup